cet ancien secrétaire d'état au
numérique là qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
là dessus qu'est ce qu'on peut faire a
tué parce que ça commence elle a l'art
en ce moment on l'a vu dans cet attentat
c'est c'est ça qui a mené à ce drame les
arguments que vous donnez là quand il
vous écoute à l'instant c'est que vous
êtes sur la position d'eric vous dites
oui on aurait pu l'éviter mais ça les
arguments que vous donnez sinon je vous
dis ce que j'entends vous dites oui on
avait désire rendre à durban i on avait
des je vous dis oui on avait aujourd'hui
fou dans votre question cyril section
répondent oui à la question c'est atroce
si on répond non c'est à la mode mais
sur ce sujet des réseaux sociaux
qu'est ce qu'ils auraient permis de
faire il ya deux choses tout le monde a
beaucoup parlé d'anonymat mais on s'en
fiche de l'anonymat dans notre histoire
a eu très peu d'histoire anonyme dans
cette idée de riga
les gens ont parlé avec leurs vrais noms
sur les réseaux sociaux est
malheureusement le père et la même mise
100 0 6 mai et sait plus où il était pas
caché il était juste derrière donc
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas une question
d anima et la nouvelle question qu'on
pose est-ce que laëtitia via propose
dans son nouveau texte aujourd'hui c'est
pas de dire aux plateformes vous auriez
dû trouver empêcher l'anonymat de ces
personnes c'est de dire quand il ya une
parole qui met en danger la vie de
quelqu'un il faut pouvoir arrêter
et moi je veux vous dire aussi cyril que
sur ce plateau ya madame ben mohamed
vous avez été une chef de meute contre
certaines personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment contre une militante
de mon mouvement et ça je vous aime je
vous le dis je les en travers de la
gorge
vous avez donné son nom et son prénom
parce que vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec
ses idées
vous avez continué non on va le faire
ensuite moi je vais pardonner avec
madame et rhazoui vous avez vous avez si
une phrase qui était quand même
extraordinaire
je voudrais sortir le pop corn mais j'en
ai pas je vais sortir la pizza avec les
enfants pendant que un autre de vos amis
étaient en train de donner son lieu
d'habitation des détails sur sa vie
familiale et vous l'avez fait vous êtes
complice de ce type de meute en ligne je
ne sache je trouve ça inacceptable et
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui on veut les
responsabiliser et moi je pense crime
aller plus loin puisqu'il ne parle
qu'avec l'argent il faut qu on les tape
au porte-monnaie à ce que j'ai vraiment
faim il faut engager la responsabilité
pénale de leurs représentants en france
mais ça peut le faire vous le dites vous
le dites je vais proposer depuis
attendrions à plusieurs reprises les
terres d'état au numérique pourquoi
c'est pas passé ça s'est passé parce que
vous avez vu que on a fait une première
proposition de loi
c'est aussi parce que ça rapporte
beaucoup d'argent mais bon je crois qu'à
et à bakou le conseil constitutionnel
regarde pas d'argent eh oui oui mais bon
moi je pense qu'il ya des lobbyings qui
font que ça passe pas parce que ça
rapporte énormément dans leurs regards
derrière l'allemagne qui sert peut pas
passer car cette année au niveau
européen avec sylvie breton on va faire
passer des choses et au nez aux français
on verrait la syrie est un produit de
consommation et twitter par exemple sans
la haine n'aviez julian mais c'est bien
c'est comme nos métiers aller quand même
c'est ça matières premières comme le
charbon là où ils sont des matières
premières